we're wearing remote-control vibrating
panties I was more interested in what
Robins opinion was cuz obviously she's
got the equipment I can tell you that
they're not you don't want to walk
around in these all day no are you gonna
write a song girl no and it's very
uncomfortable you should see how mine
fit I mean these are not built for men
like where do you put that mine to over
the penis
be honest with you then all of a sudden
I test the mine out to see how it would
work and I didn't realize my button
controls Robins I was all the way in the
ladies room you were here in your bath
and it worked and I've mind started
vibrating in the bathroom yeah then I
turned it off Robin comes in she goes
come on let's not turn these on til we
get on the air
so I'm sitting here and all of a sudden
my vibrating panties go on and I read
and she she was checking hers out to see
if they felt good you know we should
wear these all the time because in like
if we have a signal we want to signal
each other during the show I think we
could we could just I should get these
on Fred you that's the guy you have
trouble communication seriously I always
have trouble getting all the Fred just
turn these on the fog does even come up
halfway across my ass but if you want it
over my genitals which is rare I assume
you wanna all right should we turn these
on and tell people what we feel oh wait
you see mine's not on my ween keep going
that'll help me adjust this is so weird
for a guy because it really is so weird
like it's not weird for a girl why is it
weird for a girl this is built for you
all right I'll get right on my this is
what God had in mind
my mom's Vernis whatever oh I like it I
like it oh dear it's someone speed
mm-hmm no I get it I gotta hold it in
place
Oh what you turn it off for once robbing
now oh there it is you what are you
feeling cuz I'm getting hot it's getting
hot
what do you mean it's actually
physically getting warm it's burnt yeah
it might burn a hole are you feeling
heat I don't feel - yeah I feel heat
she's got a closer contact
because you don't have any Underpants I
do you did you keep your underwear on
that was the whole idea what are these
alright good lord they're big I'm a guy
feels good
hmm you know what it is I'm not getting
aroused though no it's just what about
you know it's just does it feel nice
no is it up against the intimate of your
intimate areas it's in the general area
but you really can't get to where it
really needs to get want you justice
it's no adjusting it it's you know I'm
sitting on a lump on it there's no way
to talk about your ass I like your ass
what do you need sitting on a lump
vibrating thing is a big egg egg and so
I'm sitting on a big egg to want you
when you let the egg you could get it
closer you know what yeah I got it right
there maybe it's built for guys yes baby
talk dirty w maybe I'll get off say
something to me Jackie that's your baby
I'll turn this off yours was on - you're
still on wait are you off I feel kind of
strange in my genital region I was
hoping to get aroused man Judith what do
you want okay yeah help all right cuz
then we got to do news okay the
situation going on in Oregon okay you
put yours back on
all right
Robyn's turning me on man all right turn
it off now mine's off stop it
[Music]